hello and welcome to the shiki science
show where in this video we're going to
address the question
why do nad plus levels decline with age
and to help me address this question i'm
going to use two recent nature
publications
that have both investigated the
involvement of cd38
an enzyme that degrades nadplus and how
its activity
and expression is regulated and changed
during aging
so to break this video down i'll begin
by giving some background to what
nadplus is and introduce you to what is
a very complicated
metabolic pathway but don't worry i
won't make it complicated
well i hope not then we're going to go
straight and have a look at some of the
results from these publications
and what they actually found out and
then we'll take this information
together
and there's actually a very good analogy
by eric ferdin who was one of the
main authors on one of the papers and i
think that will help you to understand
what they found out in these papers and
so we can use that to then evaluate
the take-homes from these papers and how
that falls in with nad plus
supplementation
so i feel like it's been a while since i
did a video on nad plus so let's just
start with the basics
what actually is it well nad stands for
nicotinamide adenine dinucleotide
and it comes in two forms an oxidized
state known as nad plus
and a reduced form known as nadh and the
switching between these two different
states makes
nad plus a really important cofactor
within our cells
in fact to quote david sinclair you
could argue nad plus
is the most important molecule in the
body maybe with the exception of
atp but without either of them you're
dead within 30 seconds
and that's because nadplus is required
for around 500 different enzymatic
reactions
and its two major functions can be split
into two
firstly nadplus can act as a redox
coenzyme by alternating between its
oxidized and reduced states and that's
really important for metabolism
but nad is also used as a substrate by
nad consuming enzymes
and these include sertoins and parp1
and also cd38s i've spoken about cert
one in a previous video
and pop one are proteins that act in
response to dna damage
and you'll learn more about cd 38 in
this video so hopefully from this is
pretty evident that nadplus is a pretty
important
co-factor within ourselves however nad
plus levels have been shown multiple
times to decline with age
and so there's a lot of hype and
excitement around being able to boost
these nad plus levels as we age to
counteract the age-associated
consequences of having low nad plus
levels
to be able to do this day we need to
understand why nad plus declines in the
first place
and there are two main reasons for this
either the production of nad plus
declines
or the consumption of nad plus increases
and these aren't necessarily mutually
exclusive they could both
both be happening and so here i'm using
the analogy of eric farden the current
president of the bach institute
who's also one of the main authors on
one of these recent nature publications
and he uses the analogy that if we
consider nad plus as being the water
source
then nad plus production would be the
full set
and nad consumption would be the sink
and so as we age there seems to be lower
levels of nad plus
and so it wasn't clear until these
papers whether or not
the decline stems from a decreased
production of nad plus
so there's a problem with the faucet or
from increased degradation of nad plus
analogous to a leaky sink and to place
this
analogy onto nadplus metabolism
there are many different ways in which
nad plus can be synthesized
either using the de novo pathway from
tryptophan
or by the salvage of nad plus from
precursors
going from nicotinamide nam to nmn
nicotinamide mononucleotide
back to nad plus and as you can also see
on this diagram
nad plus can be consumed by three
different enzymes sertoins
cd38 and part 1. now previous work has
shown that the protein levels of cd38
increases during aging and this can be
seen in multiple tissues
mice completely lacking this protein
were protected
from age-related nad decline and it also
had enhanced metabolic health
and mitochondrial function and so this
was suggesting that cd38 is a primary
nad plus consuming enzyme
potentially responsible for age-related
nad decline in the tissues
but it raises the following questions
why is cd38
increasing in expression and what cells
are expressing the cd38
and so these are just some of the
questions that these two nature
publications were trying to address
the first one is senescent cells promote
tissue nad plus decline during aging for
the activation of cd38 plus
macrophages and the second one fixes a
little bit more in cd 38
cd 38 ecto enzyme in immune cells is
induced during aging and regulates nad
plus and nmn levels
now both of those titles are quite
mouthfuls so let's break it down
so the first study that has come out
from the buck institute
was more focusing on which cell types
are expressing cd38
and what they found was that high levels
of cd38
were being expressed in m1 like
macrophages
and this could be seen in particular in
white adipose tissue
and within the liver of mice and this
increased expression of cd38 within
these m1 like macrophages
was associated with reducing the tissue
nad plus levels
and these m1 like macrophages
accumulated
during aging and acute responses to
inflammation
now macrophages are a type of immune
cell
and so they can be activated in response
to inflammatory factors
so it's interesting to note that the
authors found that senescent cells
were accumulating also in the white
adipose tissue and the liver during
aging
a key feature of senescent cells being
the secretion of
this senescence-associated secretory
phenotype that includes inflammatory
factors
now if you want to understand what
senescence cells are better then i
recommend you watching one of my
previous videos talking about senescence
um i just haven't really got time to go
into too much detail here
and so as i said these senescent cells
have a secretory phenotype and one of
these factors
is the cytokine interleukin-6 and the
authors showed that
interleukin-6 alone was sufficient to
induce cd38
expression in macrophages and so this
made a connection between
the sasp the secretory phenotype of the
senescent cells
and this activation of these m1 like
macrophages expressing
cd38 now if you're wondering what the m1
of m1 macrophage means it just refers to
the
type of macrophage there being m1 and
m2 macrophages and so a general take
home from this first publication
is that aging related inflammation is
enhancing nad degradation
due to an increase in cd38 levels in m1
macrophages
now some of the findings within this
first paper are validated
by the second paper however in the
second paper they focus a little bit
more on the receptor which is cd38
and how the nad levels change when the
cd38 is inhibited
and so cd38 is a really interesting
protein
and this is because it's enzymatic
domain basically
the parts of the protein that degrades
nad
can only face one side of the membrane
so either the enzymatic domain is inside
the cell or is outside the cell
and the majority of cd38 has an
orientation
such that the enzymatic domain is facing
the outside of the cell
and so it raises the question as to how
if it's facing outside the cell
is it regulating nad levels within a
cell
and so hopefully i haven't confused you
with that but what they go on to
demonstrate
in this study is that's the ecto
enzymatic
activity so the activity outside the
cell
is regulating the nicotinamide
nucleotide levels
and that part of this is being mediated
by the extracellular degradation of the
nad plus precursor nmn
as what they tease apart in this study
by using a variety of different
inhibitors of
cd38 both different compounds
and antibodies that can inhibit the
activity of cd38
to show that what seems to be the case
is that cd38
is controlling the availability of nmn
to other cells
but my favorite part of this study was
when they administered
one of the antibodies that inhibits cd38
activity
known as ab68 and they administered this
antibody to mice
and they found that it increased the nad
plus levels in the white adipose tissue
and it also increased the levels of the
nad plus precursor
nmn and so what they then did was
inhibits
the production of nmn by blocking the
enzyme nampt which is the enzyme
involved in the synthesis of nmn
and then what they could see was that
this inhibition of nampt
abrogated the boosting in levels of nmn
and nad plus
caused by this antibody 68 in the white
adipose tissue
and so bottom line is that it shows the
nmn is required for the antibody 68
induced nad blast boosting now if you've
made it this far
congrats my brain is definitely aching a
bit
so don't worry it's all downhill from
now as we'll pull together
all of this information now the easiest
way to do this is probably to go back to
the
forcer and sink analogy i used at the
beginning of the video that i've stolen
from eric ferdin
and so what he says in this news article
about this publication
is what their data shows is that the
decline
seen in the production of nad plus
during aging seems to be
more of an issue due to a leaky sink as
opposed to an issue in production of nad
plus
and so one way to compensate for a
decline in nad plus levels of aging
is to supplement with nad plus
precursors
i'd say what eric says is that
ultimately i think supplementation will
be part of the equation
but filling the sink without dealing
with the leak will be insufficient to
address the problem
and so basically this study doesn't
negate the potential benefits of taking
nad plus precursors it just suggests
that
what would be even more effective would
be ways of preventing this increased
level and activity of cd38 that is a
key culprit in the decline in nad plus
levels
partially through also degrading nmn
now you might be thinking well why
didn't we just try and inhibit cd38 then
well future studies will be required to
try and investigate better
the importance of cd38 in macrophages
and to try and better understand why it
is that they seem to upregulate cd38
nonetheless eric ferdin says in this
article as well
that there's preliminary data suggesting
that blocking cd38
activity in older animals restores nad
plus levels in specific tissues
moreover instead of cd38s these studies
also show the importance of senescent
cells and actually being upstream and
driving
cd 38 activation and the macrophages
through the secretary inflammatory
phenotype and so
having synolytics that kills senescent
cells or synamorphics
which are thought to ameliorate the
secretory phenotype could be alternative
potential therapeutic options
to help boost nad plus levels and so
also be interesting to see
future studies that try and take these
combinatorial
approaches into account now it probably
would have made more sense for me to
have done the enemy giveaway in this
video than my previous video
but i'm still going to be cheeky and
tell you that
if you use the discount code cheeky you
can get 10
off at do not age.org where they have a
variety of different
supplements on cell including nmn but
please see the disclaimer in the
description
and so congrats again for making it to
the end of this video
i felt like this was quite a challenging
one at least for me reading both those
papers
was a big toll on my brain
but they were really interesting papers
um it was a good pain
um anyway hopefully you've learned
something in this video and
as always thanks for listening